[Musique]
un petit théâtre à ivry sur seine la
tension est palpable dans cette salle de
répétition
passage en revue discipline militaire
ici les mèches rebelles ne sont pas
autorisés
dans moins d'un mois ces douze jeunes
femmes se présenteront à l'élection de
miss mali france un concours organisé
depuis dix ans par l'association
deuxième génération qui fait la
promotion de la double culture franco
malienne
batoma doumbia était étudiante et membre
du conseil municipale d'epinay-sur-seine
né en france il ya 25 ans elle se
présente pour la première fois
du haut de ses talons elle marche dans
les pas de son aîné dans le sahara et
ses amis sont à l'origine justement de
deuxième génération
l'espagne voit les tout premiers
concours jd oui en fait accompagner
makanza
y voilà donc après
chaque année j'ai suivi l'élection
[Musique]
fatoumata tant de gens et membre de
l'organisation élue deuxième dauphine il
ya un an elle s'est présentée malgré les
préjugés familiaux défiler sur un podium
un exhibitionnisme parfois mal considéré
au sein d'une société malienne très
hiérarchisée ont fait au mali et les
casses toi donc des griots il ya les
castes des nobles des mots et de ceux
qui sont pas noble et plusieurs
caténaires par exemple une personne
venant de sept cas cela ne peut pas ni
chanter ni danser inch pas beaucoup aux
autres donc le fait que je sois ce
concours un que je donne sur scène les
gens
[Musique]
une vingtaine d'ethnie existe au mali
chacune possède sa propre langue et son
propre mode de vie une identité
culturelle fondamentale qui structure la
société
cette diversité on la retrouve au sein
même de l'organisation de miss mali
france les 12 et ni les plus importantes
sont représentés par 12 candidates
nantes aînée kate à 23 ans elle aussi
est né en france ce concours c'est aussi
l'occasion pour elle de plongée dans une
culture qu'elle connaît mal
pour les filles encore beaucoup de
travail l'enjeu est de taille la
gagnante représentera la communauté
malienne de france lors de la 26e
édition de miss mali au pays
[Musique]
ce soir bat thomas et d'antenne est au
rendez vous avec deux copines dans un
restaurant du 9e arrondissement
c'est pas écrit en français
à table l'élection est au centre des
préoccupations
[Musique]
personnes
oui pour le casting déjà on savait que
pendant cattini il pouvait avoir des
questions sur le mali c'est à dire les
présidents et les ministres conviendrait
gens
je savais je pense qu'on a toutes un peu
plancher dans des bouquins où sont aussi
d'internet sur wikipédia et compagnie
pour avant des plus enrichir déjà ce
qu'on savait déjà franchement je sais
pas pourquoi mais j'ai le profit avec
manuella maury mais franchement je
pourrais pas l'expliquer mais hier c'est
trop je sais pas pourquoi je mets des
raisons mais c'est ça j'ai dit à mon
pays aussi riche m la panne est vrai que
j'aime ce faire j'aime trop
j - 1 ce soir les miss sont attendus
dans un hôtel porte de bagnolet pour une
dernière immersion déception ici pas de
5 étoiles mais douches collectives et
lits superposés
mais à 24 heures de défilé les filles se
mettent la pression pour être élu demain
antennes et doit impérativement régler
les derniers détails
[Musique]
après les répètes nantes est né laisse
la chambre à son ami atiné 90% des
maliens sont musulmans à leur concours
de beauté ou pas la 5ème prière de la
journée est un rituel immuable
pas facile pourtant de situer la mecque
depuis un autel du 20e arrondissement
alors le tapis de prière à boussole
intégrée est bien pratique
c'est aussi ça la double culture un
grand écart entre traditions religieuses
et émancipation de la femme
c'est le grand soir aux folies bergères
une des salles les plus prestigieuses de
la capitale
les supporters sont venus en nombre
et les dragueurs aussi
s'avérer bien grande d'en parler la
langue bien foncé comme moi
en coulisses atelier maquillage
près de 800 personnes sont attendues ce
soir pour une élection particulière
cette année le mali fête ses 50 ans
d'indépendance
tout un symbole
et mes grands-parents
dernière photo souvenir pour le profil
facebook
[Musique]
comme on dit chez vous à auby celui-là
soyez les bienvenus
bienvenue au mali aujourd'hui vous êtes
ici au mali on est en france mort n'est
là pour l'élection miss france
[Applaudissements]
et les zorros suis tellement ému
batoma doumbia pour les six combats
[Musique]
ce soir bat thomas et nantes est née
défileront quatre fois chacune sur la
scène des folies bergère
après trois heures de spectacle c'est
enfin l'heure des délibérations
savoir qui est la miss mali france 2011
[Applaudissements]
batoma restera ce soir au pied du podium
en revanche immense joie pour nantes est
née elle est deuxième dauphine
[Musique]
la 10e édition du concours est un succès
l'objectif de surfer sur la double
culture est largement atteint dès ce
soir les trois mises gagnantes sont en
représentation fier d'être malienne en
france